and we had a very great game we had a
memorable game we had a a i wish the
patriots and seahawks were in the same
division type game and would play twice
a year instead of once every four years
type of a game last night as as the
seattle seahawks my seahawks held off
your patriots
on sunday night football yeah i mean
first it was an amazing game it really
was i mean just
the way first off i think the thing that
jumps out to me the different approaches
by both teams it's just refreshing to
see on each on each side of the ball you
know but i think the thing that'll jump
out to me more than anything and because
we could talk about both quarterbacks
and wax poetically yeah we got to start
about russell wilson first off we
haven't seen anybody here in the last
few years tear up that patriots defense
like we just saw last night with passing
plays and things like that very rare to
see
any passing offense really function at
that high of a level
his ability to
oh wait i've gotten on the edge and it
looks like they got me oh i'll cut
inside and get five yards on a first
down i mean he gave the patriots
multiple headaches last night and i
think everything we saw from bill
belichick like in the week as far as i
don't see anybody playing better than
him right now i think bill belichick
showed that like mike you heard chris
collinsworth in the first half he was a
little bit like shocked with the
patriots and how they were playing
defense they're usually man-to-man in
your face like we don't back down and
we're gonna be all over your stuff bill
belichick like backed off like he was
like i'm not getting in the face of this
crew the hell with that these guys can
run and that's sucker russ he'll go
bombs away on me right away i'm gonna
play zones and not let them do anything
uh to get big plays and of course it
still didn't matter it didn't and i just
think that's where we're at russell
wilson mahomes lamar jackson they've
crossed over into like unstoppable mode
with the things they can do
and i found that to be the first thing
that jumped out at me about the game
last night mike
put the graphic back up please of
russell wilson's performance so far this
year
he's got 11 incompletions in two games
nine touchdown passes in two games his
passer rating
despite a pick six early last night
140.0
wow he has completed
82.5
of his passes and chris
let's just start right there yeah we're
going to get to the ending of the game
it was it was a
final play reminiscent of a super bowl
from a few years ago involving these two
teams although the roles were reversed
and the play call was reversed right but
with russell wilson he talked to peter
king after the game
and
he's embracing the concept of being the
best quarterback in football he told dan
patrick on friday when asked are you the
best quarterback in football i believe i
am without a doubt he said to peter king
i want to be the best in the world if
i'm not thinking like that i'm not going
to be successful and what he added was
there's things he wants to do
right and and peter said yeah he wants
to win a championship well i think it's
more than that i think that
russell wilson in his early 30s is
starting to appreciate his football
mortality
and also his place in football
immortality we said this last week
if you have one super bowl championship
to cap an illustrative career you're
possibly aaron rodgers to be determined
on that right if you have zero you're
dan marino right yeah or dan fouts or
friend targeting if you have six you're
tom brady russell wilson understands if
he's gonna break toward all-time
greatness he's got to get more super
bowls and it's not about one it's about
multiple and he's got one
through eight seasons this is season
number nine and i think this is the
origin of the entire let russ cook
mantra but we're seeing it play out he
went to them he went to us initially at
the super bowl he said it to the media
but he said it to them this is how he
wants to play he's good enough to excel
and we've seen it the throws last night
good god maybe he is the best
quarterback in football right now we're
just wired to think it's patrick mahomes
well i mean it's okay to have the
argument and go i don't know this guy
that guy they're both awesome it doesn't
really matter but you're right i mean
it's an argument i think it's a legit
argument where you can sit there
and no doubt
just go okay i mean one game one play
i don't taking care of the football how
to win a football game situational
football
it's all extremely close between between
both of them especially i mean they're
playing at an extremely high level and
wilson's just in another level of
efficiency right now plus we haven't
seen wilson really
be a part of
you know for lack of a better phrase of
patrick mahomes style offense where it's
just hey hey big guy getting the shotgun
we got weapons around you start wheeling
and dealing this is really the first
time we're seeing it where they're just
saying go ahead forget it we're not
going to bang our head against the wall
and run for the first two quarters of
the game and get down by 10 and tell you
to come back
you know last night even though they ran
the football and there was balance it's
different than what we saw in years past
it started the game started with them
attacking through the pass game and it's
just a different feel altogether plus as
we see they got a freak of nature in dk
metcalf
uh who's
i think along with russ we can start
talking about like i don't know is he
one of the five best receivers in the
game is he one of the two best three
best it doesn't matter we haven't seen
anybody do what he did to stefan gilmore
since uh he's been in new england the
last three years especially gilmore and
dk put it to him was not intimidated by
him so it's just a new mantra and i
think it's very exciting to watch how
they've kind of uh just flipped over the
their their culture and the way they are
i guess is how they play is what i'm
trying to say
yeah i don't think dk metcalf is ever
going to be intimidated by anybody see
how cut up he is and how big he is and
it still is amazing he almost made it
all the way to round three
last year i think i'm gonna mention that
every time we talk about deep [ __ ] it's
ridiculous my god i mean if we're going
to talk about teams that passed on great
quarterbacks what's wrong with talking
about teams that pass on great receivers
look at all the teams that passed on
michael thomas same idea this is dk
metcalf coming into his own and when you
have an offense that's going to throw
the ball the way the seahawks are not
throwing the ball you're going to have
stars develop in the passing game and
that's what dk metcalf definitely can be
russell wilson spoke after the game here
he is following that great victory over
the patriots
i think i think the most touchdowns in a
two-game stretch for you
what's working maybe perhaps more than
in the past
um i think guys are just making
tremendous plays you know i think that
you know coach shoddy is doing an
unbelievable job of calling plays you
know
we're mixing mixing the ball you know
ball up in terms of who's catching it
who's touching it in terms of the
running game and everything else and i
think the guys up front are doing a
great job man they're giving me time to
make throws and
allow me to try to make some of these
throws and stuff like that so
um i just think it all comes down to the
kind of guys you have in the room you
know on the field and everything else
and let me just say this and i'm
reminded of it because he has his neck
gator around his neck
which is where neck gators tend to go
there were shots of him late in the game
on the sideline with his neck gator up
over his mouth and nose you don't see
that from players during games so my
wife noticed that we were watching the
end of the game and she appreciates that
because look this is a time when the nfl
is getting ready to smack down some of
these coaches who refuse to pull their
gator or their mask over their mouth and
nose including your guy kyle shanahan
who i don't know why he bothers to have
it around his neck i mean he's going to
get whacked today by the nfl i think so
and if he doesn't start doing it he's
going to get whacked even harder next
week that's the way they're going to do
this right but you know i i mean russell
wilson number one concerned about his
family he's got a young baby at home but
number two it sends the right message
yeah at a time when there's this i'm
sorry to veer into the politics but
there's this it shouldn't be political
this is ridiculous debate about whether
or not you can save your life by wearing
a damn mask and it's great to see
somebody in a position of influence like
russell wilson setting an example that
could change someone's mind that if
there is anyone on the fence on this
issue and i doubt there is it's just the
kind of example that we need to see so
even more credit to one of the best
quarterbacks in football for doing the
right thing when he's standing on the
sideline watching the game he does
always the right thing i mean that's why
you pay him 35 million dollars a year
it's probably why he should he could ask
for more i mean he's he's i mean
who's more professional stand-up guy
just wears your franchise better than
than russell wilson
i mean he's he's really the perfect
quarterback from that standpoint you
never have to worry about getting in
trouble you never have to worry about
him saying anything bad about anybody on
your football team you never have them
have to worry about him saying anything
disrespectful about the other team to
give them bill
bulletin board material and then
go ahead and then you never have to
worry about anything except oh he's
gonna come in here and try to work his
hardest to try to be the greatest of all
time oh man what a what a bad one they
picked there in seattle
i i i i but you know what i just had a
thought what about russell wilson
because he's been mocked for being goody
two-shot yeah right throughout his
career right go hawk and here's the
difference yeah here's the difference
well you know what i talked to him last
week he didn't say go hawks damn it
we've had him on set he doesn't he's
starting to but and maybe this is the
extent of it but but he did do it last
night on uh
yes but but you know i had i had a
thought here now what the hell it's
monday morning let's have some fun
greece is on netflix and and to me i was
like an early teenager 11 12 when we
went to see greece in the theater it was
just a moment and i watched it recently
and it brings back all those memories
and it is every bit as cheesy and corny
and awesome as it was 40 plus years ago
right but it's almost like russell
wilson is going through the
transformation of sandra d
to
sandy at the end and she when she shows
up but not not but he's like becoming a
badass in his own way
by embracing i'm the best quarterback in
football and yeah that's how i'm gonna
be and i'm done
standing in the shadows no more sandra d
for me i can still be
the guy who sets the right example says
the right things does the right things
but damn it i'm done taking a back seat
i'm done being being second fiddle to
any other quarterback in the nfl because
i see what these guys do and i'm as good
as all of them if not better and damn it
seahawks if you're not going to let me
go show that i'll find a team that will
let me and trust me folks i know you
don't like hearing and i know it makes
tony dungey roll his eyes but the truth
is that's the message that was sent to
the seahawks and we're seeing the end
result of it they were smart enough to
recognize we better let this guy do what
he's capable of doing and that's where
russell wilson has become a badass chris
agreed i mean i didn't think we were
talking about greece today or anything
like that beauty school drop
all these things get out of here but
either way that's the first song you go
to i don't know
the worst song in the world is the first
one the one that popped in my head i
don't know why it did but either way
well two things there first off yeah
russ you know nerd whatever corny oh
okay
the one the one thing that i think
people guys in a locker room
and especially somebody like me and
you're i think you're explaining it he's
always owned it he's never tried to be
anything else and to me guys in a locker
room just in my experience in the nfl in
my eight years they can respect that you
know they might be like ah he's a dork
but
oh i mean he's he's always the same he's
the same guy every day i appreciate that
it's not a fake he doesn't try to come
in here one day and try to be tough guy
then the next day he's you know rico
suave dressed all cool he's he's him and
i respect that about russ and i don't
think he like
you know what do i want to say fo of
just moves or changes for anybody
and then the other thing mike
seattle i got you got to give pete
carroll a lot of credit i mean just for
what he did here this was hard for him
i'm sure this is outside of his like dna
scope here to be like what throw first
bombs away i want to play four yards in
a cloud of dust with marshawn lynch and
you know hold you to 12 points and try
to win 16-12 so a lot of credit to him
and playing through the strength of his
team you know two of the three best
players on his football team are d.k
metcalf and russell wilson and then he
went wait so i can't play this ben don't
break style on defense if we're gonna
play air it out go attack on offense who
can i get to be like a crazy tasmanian
devil on the defensive side of the ball
to start making plays there or maybe we
give up a few either way but we're still
getting the ball back to russ to let him
cook and all that and they get jamal
adams so schneider pete carroll their
thoughts of what they've done on the
field and then to match it up with the
players on the field as well and what
they've done in scouting and free agency
uh phenomenal and that's why they're the
seattle seahawks your point about pete
carroll is a great one his mentor was
bud grant not don coryell yeah right
this is a defensive grounded pound three
yards and a cloud of dust type of
mentality they tripped over russell
wilson in the third round of the 2012
draft i'm not quite sure they knew what
they were getting no one knew otherwise
he wouldn't have lasted that long i
remember seeing him being interviewed
from his home
when he was picked by the seahawks and
everyone was kind of intrigued by what
this short quarterback could do in the
nfl and he's taking the nfl by storm but
look he's found i think the right
balance at this point he's always erred
on the side of not making waves and i
think he's found his voice and there's a
way
to make waves without being a villain
without being a jerk right he's still a
good guy at his heart he's still a guy
who's gonna skew toward doing the right
thing right but there's nothing wrong
with as you would say chris having some
self-confidence in yourself and that's
what he's exhibiting and he's made it
clear
that he wants to show the world what he
can do because he is chasing immortality
he's going to be 32 later this year i
believe he wants to play until he's 45
but you know i'm sure a lot of guys want
to play until they're 45 and there are
factors out of your control yeah you've
got to seize the moment while you can
and it has to be hard for him to look in
the rearview mirror and recognize i've
been
in this league now eight spins around
the sun and i've only got one super bowl
to show for it and yeah i may end up
being aaron rodgers or brett favre not
that there's anything wrong with being
all-time greats but it's it's the rings
especially with what brady's done it's
the rings that determine whether or not
you're you're in the pantheon of
all-time greats yeah no you're right at
the end of the day the average fan they
just boil it down to that and always go
to the rings discussion he's already
getting into the discussion of all time
great for me uh as far as that's
concerned but but either way i mean i
know what you're saying you win a second
super bowl you start to get into two and
three you go to another stratosphere
there's no doubt about that and i think
that point is real and i think that
you're right he's trying to get there
he's obsessed with it that's all he's
gonna talk about um but man quarterback
and play in general last night because
we didn't talk about the other freak on
the other side do you want to go there
now because that's well yeah and here's
let's set the stage because it was
beautiful symmetry to super bowl 49
different quarterback for the patriots
right but super bowl 49 as we know ended
on the one yard line with russell wilson
throwing the ball instead of the
seahawks dialing up a run and here come
the patriots it was 35 24 i declared it
to be over
and 35 23 whatever it was 35 23 i said
it's over
foolishly and here come the patriots 35
30 driving down the field and they get
that last play from the one-yard line
and chris what did you see as that
fateful play unfolded well it's a play
they've gone to we saw this last week we
saw it during this game i believe two
other times and big moments and really
great job by pete carroll because after
the patriots get to completion right
they line up in the formation pete
carroll and seahawks call timeout
because they go uh oh here they go
they're gonna put 9000 pounds on the
line of scrimmage and try to overpower
us and to me the biggest difference was
this number 91 lj collier he's the guy
that makes the play he's the guy that
hits cam newton's legs and makes him
flip up into the air it was the first
time all game on that play that he
played on the outside edge of the tackle
he didn't try to like dart inside to
clog the middle and then leave that edge
on the outside where we saw cam newton
kind of run through untouched i believe
two other times this time he got on the
edge of that shoulder of that tackle
bounced off and made an unbelievable
play really did and i mean mike what
were you doing there were you sitting
there cause i was like
man what are the patriots gonna do are
they gonna run it they've had great
success here but i was like man
seattle's going to be foaming at the
mouth i i was really thinking like maybe
i passed it
i know i thought joshua might throw that
just thinking they might go all out to
stop the run but
the pop pass they did the pop past
earlier in the game right i i i think if
you put josh mcdaniels under a little
sodium pentothal he'd say i wish i'd
have held that until the end of the game
yeah probably probably it's you know
it's tough though at the same time just
to not call a play that's been so
like successful so far the first two
weeks of the year right we haven't seen
anybody even come close
to stopping them at the line of
scrimmage when they've done that yet so
they will
yeah until then but but i'm never gonna
fault the team for going to the bread
and butter just like the super bowl 49
that we're talking about you know hey we
wanted to see marshawn they didn't do
that so we all got pissed off and what
are you doing seattle you're crazy this
big sucker just broke seven tackles to
play before to get you to the one yard
line why wouldn't you give it to him
again i have a feeling we'd be saying
the same thing too though if they did
try to do the pass and somebody
tipped it or it didn't work out the
right way to go why wouldn't you just
run it with 900 pounds of cam newton and
lead blockers and everything like that
so i'm not gonna fault the call it was
just a great play by seattle and new
england went to the well probably one
too many times on that one
you've heard from us on the final play
let's hear now from some of the key
figures uh who influenced and actually
participated in that moment
was right into the coaches mind as they
make the decision there
about what you would think it would be
we had one play to score and we tried to
go with what we thought was our best
play
what else is there to think about
you know i saw a clip of it
i could i could have made it right by
just bouncing it
i was just trying to be patient just
thinking too much man normally or even
just diving over the top i you know so
many different things that flashed over
me and and playing the fast defense like
that as soon as you guess
you're wrong
we took a shot at that play had been
real successful for him earlier and and
uh so we got after it and the guys did a
fantastic job of adjusting right there
on the fly and
we got it done it was an amazing play
amazing moment
i'd love to go back out there and do it
all over again if we could
yeah maybe they will in a few months
chris
uh they both both teams are looking
pretty damn good and it's a shame
someone had to lose that one i look i i
understand why you play to your strength
in that spot and you know how it goes
yeah if it works if it works
hey you're a genius if it doesn't work
and even if you're bill belichick
usually when it doesn't work for bill
belichick you don't get questioned but
rarely do we see a situation like that
where the patriots are on the brink of a
victory in an up or down win or lose
pass fail scenario right and it doesn't
work out for them well how often does
that happen right it doesn't it's it
usually doesn't happen i mean they're
not in that situation very often because
usually they're winning the game not
trying to come back and win it on the
last drive but uh you know you look hey
bottom line is you got to call a play
you got to give it a try and you never
know what the alternative would have
done period we're not privy to an
alternate universe where they passed it
at the goal line instead of running it
so maybe a pass wouldn't have worked
either no i mean who knows
you know and you're right hey listen
chris collinsworth he's all over these
two teams right i mean he knows
everything he gives us so many good
things to talk about and think about
during the game even him during the game
was going this this play is unstoppable
they can't nobody's gonna stop this so i
understand it i do you can't fault the
play seattle
just made a great play and a big moment
uh and new england will readjust you're
right we don't see new england come up
short very much in those type of
situations definitely not but i think
there is a silver lining for new england
because we went into the game going wait
the new england run game all the tricky
things you can do with cam newton what
are they going to do there's no weapons
in the pass game there's no weapons you
know how is he going to be able to throw
the football because that's what i was
told all year you know last year that's
all we heard
so
how about that
i mean yes he can throw the football
this is just going to make this is a
game even though they lost i really
think new england's offense is going to
come away going okay there's nothing we
can't do we're it's official this big
guy here understands how to read the
field he can make unbelievable throws
scrambled when he need to
and then of course all the things they
could do in the run game and everything
like that so it's something to build on
nonetheless i think that's what's
encouraging for cam newton the patriots
mcdaniels belichick we're still early on
in their shelf life here and they've
shown us two weeks of going whoa there's
some big time potential here
it's a pick your poison type of an
offense much like what the chiefs are
trying to develop with rookie clyde
edwards elaire however though and we can
focus on the decision at the goal line
but
the reality is maybe they should have
had more than one crack at the goal line
yeah that's that's real the curious
decision let's set the stage here first
and ten from the seattle 31
the ball was snapped with 36 seconds on
the clock
they get the ball down to the seattle 13
on an 18-yard pass to julian edelman
right and then it's tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick
twenty three total seconds went off the
clock between the start of the first
play and the start of the next play i
mean there's some valuable
opportunities there to get the ball
close to the end zone and punch it over
and you're still at the 13. what are you
doing you're it's not like you're on the
three you're at that 13.
and uh who knows why bill belichick did
what he did let's hear from bill
belichick directly on why he did what he
did or or maybe we won't hear from him
much at all here he is
was there a thought at all to take a
time out after the long play to julian
there at the end
seattle took a timeout
i mean what are you talking about
i think the clock ran down from 36
seconds to
13 after the 18-yard completion of
edelman
yeah well
he's still sitting there for those of
you listening on siriusxm211 bill
belichick is still sitting there
and stacy james
eventually intervenes and says let's go
to the next question so that answered it
that was the answer
i got nothing to say i got nothing to
say and you know we're just a week
removed from vic fangio with that head
scratching failure to to call timeouts
late in the game against mike frable and
the titans this was worse i mean you're
at the 13 you still have work to do
i don't know was he surprised by the
fact that they got the ball down to the
13 it just was odd but uh uh and this is
so different because remember belichick
did this against the seahawks at super
bowl 49 as they were moving closer and
closer to the goal line he didn't call
timeouts in order to get the ball back
this wasn't about using timeouts to you
know give yourself more time to score
this is hey i don't want to get the ball
back with three seconds left if they do
score and when he didn't call that
timeout people wonder what was going on
and i think he looked across the
sideline and he sensed the disarray
that was happening in seattle and he
thought you know what if i just go ahead
and let them continue this they're going
to do something that is going to help us
tremendously and they ultimately did the
disarray last night was on his own
sideline who's not calling the time out
there who's making that decision to not
kill the clock when you've got timeouts
again you don't take them home with you
and you better use them while you can
while you still have time to try to
reverse the outcome yeah listen it was
shocking there's no doubt about it now i
think there's two things here first off
i mean you're right you never see bill
make these type of mistakes it's very
rare very rare i mean it's very
calculated i think the fact that he
didn't answer that in the way he
answered it kind of tells you
he probably doesn't like his own
decision when it came to that either and
real realizing that but i think the
other two things too here would be and i
don't know why he didn't call time out
but i'm just trying to
one it took a little bit longer for them
to get up to the line and spike the ball
the other thing is julian edelman caught
the ball on the sideline going out of
bounds i do wonder if they just thought
like wait did he go out of bounds did we
get a clock stoppage it just seemed like
hey we got the pass and it was a little
bit of a delay before i saw cam going
like hey come on everybody let's spike
it you know and giving all the signals
and doing all that so maybe there was
some indecisiveness there either way
you're right it's very rare and when i
watch back on tv i think on that that
that play that was snapped at 36 seconds
that you're talking about i believe the
guy was tackled with 29 seconds and then
they don't stop the clock till nine so
that's still 2016. yeah yeah
it was it was it was down to 13 seconds
when the next play started right um
and then the timeout was taken by
seattle after that play more to kind of
gather and regroup right it wasn't to
stop the clock that's what made bill's
explanation even stranger seattle didn't
take a time out to stop the clock the
clock was stopped after the incompletion
of edelman with nine seconds left after
that play nobody took a time out to kill
the clock while it was tick tick tick
ticking away what could have been
another i don't know it was first and
goal at the one i don't know how many
opportunities they would have had if
that first one didn't go through now
here's and here's a play i think they
costed themselves a play they costed
themselves one more shot now the timeout
came in handy because they could attack
and got the ball at the one one yard
line but i do think that
if they take the time out after that
play maybe it's two plays really
right i mean
again especially if you talk about like
attacking the end zone right mike where
it's like we're going to attack the end
zone maybe all four times then i do
think they probably could have got four
plays off yeah certainly but
you know at the same time i don't know
they could have thrown a ball down to
the one yard line and had to get up
there and spike the ball and we could
have been in the same scenario too so
uh but let's break it down let's break
it down go ahead
from the moment they got to the 13 and
didn't call the timeout they had three
more plays they had the pass to julian
edelman that was dropped they had the
pass to nikhil harry down to the one the
12 yarder that it almost got to the end
zone the pass to julian the time out of
the ball wasn't it isn't that just this
okay it's spiking right right so it's it
may have been spike yeah it says passing
complete short middle to julian oh
that's right he did that
okay
and then they had the the last play
first and goal from the one right so so
let's let's go alternate universe they
call timeout with 29 seconds left when
that play ends yeah they got first and
10 from the 13 with 29 seconds now
that's their last out they would have
been out of timeouts at that point
but
your first intent from the 13 with 29
sec 29 seconds left yeah first and ten
from the 13. you got enough time to run
a play up the middle and spike it
quickly because your guys aren't moving
very far they got 13 yards between where
they are in the end zone
i think you you you get and you get i
then there's less of that that hair on
fire i mean you can be a little more
strategic you can be a little more
tactical and yeah if you get tackled in
bounds you can kill the clock but i i
just feel like they could have operated
a little more flexibly a little more
freely and maybe it wouldn't have been
that all eggs in one basket from the one
yard line last play of the game you know
maybe get a couple shots at the end zone
uh you can be a little more deliberate
you can you can keep seattle guessing a
little bit it just that's that's instead
of 29 seconds
there's nine seconds after that that
first play from first and 10 on the 13
and and if it was any other coach
we'd be body slamming him that's the
reality that's what six rings buys you
folks if it was any other coach if it
was jason garrett last year with the
cowboys any other coach this year we'd
be saying what in the hell was this guy
doing not taking his time out but with
bill belichick he can sit there through
30 seconds of awkward silence and and
still not get criticized as aggressively
as any other coach no he he he won't
you're right i mean that's just the
facts of the situation and you know in a
lot of ways he deserves that too the
fact that he gets a little leeway there
i think he's proven to us that yeah he's
not perfect but damn he's the closest
thing we've ever seen as a head
[Music]
a little available
whatever that may be yeah i agreed with
you there and i'm shocked that they
didn't call the timeout i don't know
what went on and i would love to hear an
explanation maybe we'll hear something
more from bill today uh when he thinks
about this a little bit more but uh you
know regardless he's gonna be able to
walk away and go
damn
my quarterback week one show me i can
run the ball
week two he showed me hey even when they
take away the run
he can move the ball through the air and
then move the ball in very
clutch situations i mean like you know
like you said it was over down 12 right
i mean bing bang boom they're right down
the field and you're going uh oh watch
out so
uh i think that's the big thing we saw
cam newton and this offense i think come
alive in its totality and we'll see
where it goes uh from here and i will
say this last thing mike i do think last
night was the first time or it's only
the second game of course it's the first
time but dante hightower patrick chung
there's a few plays there some
miscommunication you saw swain catch the
wide open pass where no one's covering
them right i mean i think those are a
few things where you go hey there's the
newness of this patriots defense and
some of these new guys where you saw
some communication issues and some
people bust some assignments last night
that you usually don't see on that new
england defense
one last thing on cam newton before we
take a break i've seen people saying how
in the hell was cam newton unsigned all
those months
why did no one else with quarterback
needs are these the same people that
were telling me i was crazy for putting
them at number 10 in my quarterback
rankings or may have been maybe probably
the same people but now they're going to
think that's crazy right
we didn't know he was healthy nobody
knew whether or not he was healthy and
secondly the teams that already have
their entrenched starters
don't want this guy as their backup i
remember the report that came out he's
willing to be a backup but why the hell
would he be willing to be a backup if
he's healthy he should be no one's
backup so you're gonna bring in total
disruption to your team after you've
made a long-term commitment i mean think
about
and and this one's an easy one this is
as low hanging as the low hanging fruit
gets cam newton and kirk cousins right
now
um night and day difference but you've
made the 33 million a year investment in
kirk cousins you can't bring in cam
newton right and have the players
realize after one practice that cam
newton's a better quarterback overall
that he can move away from pressure
instead of collapse like a folding chair
no i it's so that that's that's the
dilemma and it worked out perfectly for
the patriots it's working out perfectly
for cam and even though they lost last
night this is a team that's going to win
plenty of games as long as cam stays
healthy and we'll see
if that happens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports